semaine chargée pour les joueuses d'ici
paraît avant le choc au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mercredi 15
mars magny les hameaux
frida textech bernie vis bleuies meriam
garba étaient réunis pour faire la
promotion du handball féminin au cm1 de
l'école louise weiss moran comptes qui a
fait le bonheur des enfants
bah ça fait du bien de rencontrer des
personnes connues dans le monde entier
j'en ai jamais vu donc voilà ça fait
plaisir
bah j'en avais jamais vus auparavant et
comme on choisit d'y handball en sport
et par na na judée des personnes qui
savaient bien y jouer
la visite d'une heure trente s'est
terminée par un bain de foule dans la
cour de récréation
[Applaudissements]
vendredi 17 mars retour sur les terrains
d'entraînement avec l'objectif d'être
prêt physiquement et tactiquement pour
le match contre brest le samedi 25 mars
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
on se prépare c'est plutôt technique
avec les en ce moment et je pense que
chacune d'autres non on a on a envie de
bien faire pour 51 c'est un endroit où
on n'a jamais joué et a jamais eu de
match de handball abad faudra qu'on
donne un bon spectacle un spectacle à
guichet fermé ils seront près de 5 me
dans l'antre du vélodrome saint
quentinois pour encourager ses joueuses
d'ici paris
[Applaudissements]